i'm going to show you a really simple
home test that you can do to determine
if you have a calcium
deficiency
now calcium deficiencies are pretty
common but usually not because the
person is not taking a supplement or not
getting it from their diet
it's mainly because either they're not
absorbing it or the body is not
utilizing it properly so in this video
we're going to talk about the symptoms
of the calcium deficiency and all of the
other reasons why you might be deficient
and then a real simple home test that
you can do okay so what are the symptoms
well number one anxiety
irritability insomnia
muscle tension spasms or cramps low back
pain constipation
high blood pressure
heart palpitations
frequent nose bleeds could be a calcium
deficiency
soft fingernails could be another
indicator frequent cold sores
sunburns when you barely go in the sun
then we have hives having frequent
fevers could be related to a calcium
deficiency because calcium lowers your
immune system i remember with our kids
every time they had a fever i'd give
them a little calcium
and it would go right away frequent
hoarseness
chronic coughing
and difficulty getting to sleep so
calcium is a mineral that we need for
our muscles our bones our tendons our
ligaments and the nervous system calcium
also acts as a communication between
your nerves and there's many things that
affect the calcium absorption okay
first thing is vitamin d if you don't
have enough vitamin d
you're not going to absorb calcium that
well if you have sufficient vitamin d
you can increase the absorption of
calcium by a factor of 20x okay that is
a major increase in calcium absorption
and of course so many people are
deficient in vitamin d now magnesium if
you're low in magnesium you're going to
have a difficult time absorbing calcium
because magnesium and calcium work
together another factor is the
hydrochloric acid in your stomach if you
don't have enough hydrochloric acid like
a lot of people over the age of 40 and
50 and 60 because as you age you have
less and less hydrochloric acid in your
stomach and you need acid to be able to
absorb certain minerals especially
calcium low essential fatty acids like
omega-3 fatty acids
essential fatty acids help you absorb
calcium and so if you're deficient in
omega-3 fatty acids
you're going to have a much more
difficult time absorbing calcium all
right next thing is low
estrogen let's say your menopausal
and you don't produce as much estrogen
that can affect your calcium another
factor is your ph
if you're too alkaline and i'm talking
about your blood
and normally blood should be alkaline
but if you're excessively too alkaline
you're going to have a difficult time
absorbing calcium as well so you may
deposit calcium in the eyes there's
cataracts and the teeth is tartar the
kidney is kidney stones in the joints
there's arthritis on the bones as
spurring so unless the ph is correct
it's going to be more difficult to
absorb calcium if you have gut
inflammation you're going to have a much
more difficult time absorbing calcium so
all of these conditions where you have
you know irritable bowel syndrome or
diverticulitis or crohn's can greatly
affect your absorption of certain
minerals especially in calcium and the
next thing is interesting hypothyroidism
you need a normal thyroid to be able to
help you absorb
calcium so if your thyroid is low like
let's say you have hashimoto's that can
be a reason why you're low in calcium
not to mention the hormone that the
thyroid produces called calcitonin if
calcitonin is low you may also have a
deficiency in calcium so as you can see
there's many different factors that go
way beyond
the dietary aspects of calcium but let's
talk about how to determine if you are
deficient in calcium so what you do is
you take this blood pressure cuff just a
standard blood pressure cuff and you're
going to wrap it around one of your
calves you're going to pump it up and
you're going to record when you start
feeling a cramp and if that number is
200 or less suspect a calcium deficiency
and of course if you have peripheral
vascular disease i don't want you to be
doing this test now there could be other
reasons but this is a pretty good
indicator if you're deficient in calcium
now if the pressure is between
200 to 220 you have sufficient calcium
and if you're between 220 and 240
you have the optimum amount of calcium
but you don't need to go above 240 and
the units you're measuring are
millimeters of mercury and what happens
when you're divisioning calcium is you
have a lot of muscle cramps at rest okay
especially when you're sleeping and this
test just
magnifies that problem a little bit more
so you can determine where your weakness
is so in the description i'm going to
put these numbers down below and
describe this
in detail so you can actually refer back
to it now if you have a calcium
deficiency before you start taking
calcium you really want to make sure
that you're solving the correct problem
because it could be a lot of other
factors so really quickly i want to give
you some additional information so let's
talk about hydrochloric acid how do you
know if you're low in hydrochloric acid
well you get indigestion
if you do
then that could be the reason
why you can't absorb calcium in which
case you need to take something like
retain hydrochloride or more apple cider
vinegar now with magnesium it's a little
more difficult i mean you can go get an
intracellular
test which is
more involved but i just have a question
for you
do you consume a good amount of leafy
greens that would be a good
indicator that you have enough magnesium
if you don't like vegetables and don't
consume vegetables chances are you could
be deficient in magnesium in which case
that's what you'd want to take to
increase the absorption of calcium and
by the way you're going to get calcium
from leafy greens now what about
essential fatty acids well you consume a
lot of fish
do you have inflammation do you have
arthritis okay
if you answered yes to any of these
maybe you need a good omega-3 fatty acid
or better yet start consuming more
salmon or sardines cod liver oil okay
things that are high in omega-3 fatty
acids the reason i like olive oil
because it not only has the omega-3 but
it also has the vitamin d at the same
time as well as vitamin a now what about
alkalinity how do we know u2 alkaline
i've done some videos on this you can
check it out but one uh common symptom
of being too alkaline and i'm talking
about your blood is that you get this
little twitch on your skin it could be
underneath the left eye could be
anywhere on your body a little it's
called tetany a little twitch that could
be a factor in which case you need to
start drinking
maybe some outside of vinegar on a
regular basis uh the change of chloride
because once you start to put the acids
back in that can help reset things but
here's the thing to really get your ph
corrected you just need to eat healthy
and your ph will come back in the
balance now what about low estrogen okay
well let's say you're menopausal okay
this could be the reason
what can you do about it there's quite a
few things i'll put a link down below if
you are menopausal to get a little bit
more information on that topic now what
about low vitamin d well do you have a
low immune system are you depressed
do you have low back pain these are all
indicators of low vitamin d is it the
middle of winter do you normally take
vitamin d or not do you get enough sun
so in other words you need to start
looking at the other reasons why you
might be deficient and see which root
cause makes the most
sense now if you haven't seen my other
video on calcium i think that video
would be the most appropriate check it
out i put it up right here